hi guys I'm Greg hi guys
I'm Jon Bernthal I'm getting the song to
song on IMDB pulled up that way everyone
knows that I'm doing a minor bit of
research and I'm looking up more
information on today's sponsor Tina Levi
doing that this is the Terrence Malick
movie I've actually been looking forward
to and not recognizing titles a few
people sent this over I forgot to
screenshot the request brother Goss is
in the Ryan Gosling is in this my hero
look out so the boys Natalie Portman
Rooney Mara Michael Fassbender Christian
Bale and Cate Blanchett Val Kilmer
Benicio del Toro Holly Hunter clifton
collins jr. oh my goodness from Terrence
Malick's yeah Terrence Mann could prove
anything he always makes consistently
extremely entertaining play
yeah very fast-paced very lot of bright
colors easy to understand lot it was the
big on how to effectively hard you never
leave confused and or bored if you've
end of contemplation they're not very
pensive or ruminant but hey you guys
enjoying and having together man yeah
like a superhero but I like an Ocean's
eleven there for some sexuality nudity
Natalie Portman's but
and in a while commenting sorry I mean I
saw you
[Music]
I'm still gonna be hard without the
control and tunnel live from sound fun
oh I had a record together no you do the
live music - but you want to make some
money is that tenant definitely okay
condition can't be left alone
[Music]
danke
whoa no oops
michael fassbender
[Music]
thank you mean ethical shot takuchyan
Gallagher even live in New York yeah my
first thought I can totally see why all
these people were cast they've all done
nothing that kind of represents this
movie they've all this is like the
graduated version of something there
yeah yeah Ryan Gosling I'm thinking of
la-la-land and Blue Valentine yeah
Michael Bachman I'm thinking like shame
or any of the many drama differences
many of these a lot of dramas shame and
that other one where he played sexist
now a poor many she's done some machine
like the other Boeing but she wasn't
brothers black swam which is at least
jarring in a human way yeah where was
crispy where's Christian Bale Oh Rooney
Mara here she plays a lot about their
character I think of you know yeah girl
de jure I get bad new right side effects
I heard her get a little bit of that
this holy looks like a Terrence Malick
film for sure is shot like every
Terrence Malick film is ablate the kind
of angles the framing the law but super
long takes which is not a bad thing
notice that it's very this is stylistic
it's like if you show me footage I go is
this directed by Terrence Malick has a
very distinct spot he do not have cup
Street yeah feels like he's making more
movies lately maybe he was just minding
his low-budget ideas yeah I think that's
what he's doing and not a cup of people
really know I didn't watch it I heard is
really dull see that's the thing I'm
always curious about him I'm always
curious as to how they're actually going
to be to watch well this looks so sad it
looks yeah it looks really sad it look
song almost kinetic like you know it
feels like you're very much there and
you're very much pretty around a lot of
inhaling notic it makes me curious about
it but I'm gonna have to really prepare
myself definitely curious you know Ryan
Gosling is just so good at being in love
and also being heartbroken okay so this
is about like what these guys are in the
music industry Michael FAAST matters
like this producer or manager who's now
[ __ ] rooney mara they [ __ ] Natalie
Portman the homeboy yeah that's fine
it's totally microphone are doing that
like a real in real life so I don't you
after what gives you that impression
look at Michael Fassbender Matt is just
so cool I would probably have sex in it
it's like you got through the coolest
actors in here Ryan Gosling and Michael
floss better it's like the lead Elise
how did you turn down Michael Fassbender
crushed crushing crossed and crush and
bail there's the males in there dude oh
do that thing that people do you got
Batman Batman you got magneto you guys
is James Foster Jane Foster you got a
girl women storm sister yeah you got you
got driver Adam drivers in the suit no
driver from at wrangling oh yeah driver
well rank often did say that was a
superhero film you know this is
interesting because this looks like a
super depressing film that I actually
really want to watch
there's something about certain hypnotic
kind of melancholy SATA tones that can
just really pull you into weird escapism
into sadness but it's not your problem
there's something like trippy about it
you know yeah I gotta want to be on
shrooms and watch this movie I I don't
know if I can handle that this is all
plays out like a bad memory the way so
you Todd yeah great day Donnie yeah yeah
look like a tree living somebody's bad
memory yeah oh boy
I named it you know that dishes me me it
doesn't seem like a lot of Terrence
Malick's recent movies have been like
very warmly regarded as you know as some
of his like earlier classic yeah but I
don't know every time he shows up I'm
always interested the problem is I
I don't think he hooked me lately enough
to the point where I'm like I'm gonna
[ __ ] like I'm making out check it out I
see the trailer wasn't ago I want to
check that out and I happened I don't
know if it's just me being lazy or if
he's if there's something about these it
doesn't quite grab me now I know I
should see this movie on my own I should
see this movie on my own I have cups
here's what happened I saw the trailer
and I thought this was pretty boring
everyone I talked to that actually saw
it which is very few people and then
like all the reviews and stuff I was
like then it feels like it's gonna be a
boring filming the last thing I want to
do is be bored
even if it's a bad I would not want to
be bored and song this song doesn't look
like it's gonna be boring yeah your [ __ ]
looks like it's gonna be like rather
depressing and like a bad memory not
because the movies bad but the way it's
all shot you know we have like a like
all that memory about it like you kind
of like not Winery living but it's
playing out yeah yeah that's in the like
thoughts for the long tasering yeah I'm
certainly in song the song so funny how
he does like you know he doesn't know I
was fully expecting like one of those go
like a sing Street to him oh yeah I mean
or in song to saw he does the notebook
Ryan Gosling he does and then he comes
out with Blue Valentine anti notebook
then he does like his la-la-land and now
he's doing a cool bike you cousin then
he did action and then he did drug
addict notebook yeah it sort of plays
out like an old music documentary like
the footage they cut to for a few
seconds in a music documentary but for a
whole 90 minutes to three hours well the
fact of the matter is I'm just so long
as cast any time where I Gosling moves
or talks I'm interested it's that simple
when it comes to that actor yeah same
thing with Michael Fassbender I saw
movie when I was in Zurich the star
Michael Fassbender I totally forgot what
it's called I wash it with jobs like BIC
and for some reason all alien covenant
yeah we got real girl extremes are we
good we thought we both didn't do
reviews on it
if Michael phosphorescence creepy no no
no no no it was his like is like a drama
about him leaving x-men the new one
trust me I don't think you're gonna get
it but Michael Fassbender is great in
this movie he's great and I don't really
love the movie but I'd like Michael
Osmonds amazing he has that person out
president he came out and said that he
thought he kind of sucked in x-men Days
of Future past I was like you were one
of the best things I've ever loved you
like I'm so surprised I was so really
pulled into the magneto story and all
this other [ __ ] going on with it you
know ultimate sonography yeah I guess
I'm going to watch this I want to start
seeing more movies a and B I want to
start seeing you know making an effort
to go see more it's out there film we
watch get out and cure for wellness
earlier than most people
yeah yeah it's working my wish is
working but even today as a human being
I would like to see more movie in the
month because I only see the ones that
we review lately when I do watch along
we're going to watch along you know
watching this well he live long - near
the channel subscribers a real rejects
Jonathan - Gary on Instagram and Twitter
and he is the manager of zero showing
media forward the real rejects and blah
blah blah blah mwah glum house Blum
house